it is perfectly obvious
to me anyway that psychedelics so
challenge
uh cultural values
that a society has to be incredibly
confident
of its first premises to allow its
citizens to habitually and regularly
explore altered states of consciousness
that's a level of democratic dialogue
that would rip this society asunder i
mean american society cannot function
without a vast deep hidden dark closet
into which nobody ever looks and no
rhetoric ever penetrates and if it did
the whole enterprise would just rip at
the seams every once in a while this
happens
the president's blow job a case in point
but
you know we move very slowly and
cautiously in these
areas um
but
but
nevertheless curious intellectual elites
feeling the existential on we imposed by
scientific materialism have
have
made special rules for themselves and
throughout the 20th century we have had
the phenomenon of bohemian culture
experimenting with sexual mores
experimenting with intoxicants of
various sorts experimenting with ideas
and i mean the bohemian community in a
little larger sense than simply the
artistic community because there has
always been a bohemian community in
science as well
renegade scientists the the rupert
sheldrakes of of the world represent
essentially the denizens of scientific
bohemia
uh
this
and someone could argue with this
premise but i would argue with them and
win i tell you
uh
the enormous explosion of creativity
artistic scientific in popular culture
in design and fashion in literature
throughout the 20th century has been
driven
by generically
this social disequilibrium
movement of people and ideas and in the
background of that
psychedelics
the entire internet computer
revolution rides on the backs of people
who were taking lsd in the 60s and
people have expressed horror at this
idea and then taken opinion polls at
various professional gatherings such as
seagraph and and
and
comdec and
gatherings like that and
had this insight confirmed
overwhelmingly
the entire
post
1950s edifice of information transfer
and replication technology was created
by uh psychedelic people and is serving
them very well as well as a corporate
elite
and so
what i see happening is the the dirty
and unspoken secret of the 20th
century's phenomenal diversity and
creativity
is its relationship to artificial
stimulation of the imagination
uh by by whatever means
and
we're now so late in the 20th century so
late in the unfolding of modernity that
i think it's all right to talk about
this
now
the
creativity loop is very short i mean
people are inspired and they can
implement through coding on the internet
through
graphic tools that they have at their
disposal and so faster and faster the
imagination is
vivifying itself it is becoming more
imminent and this is what what the
future is the future is a breakdown of
the notion of uh of three-dimensional
linear newtonian space to be replaced by
a fractal landscape of a trillion
private idahos that are
all uh reacting to each other and
integrating with each other and leaping
over each other in a dimension much
deeper
and much more
variable than the social dimension that
we're used to seeing societies function
in and i
think that to
if you're paying attention or if you're
semi-unemployed as i am
you realize that you can spend all your
time
simply trying to
understand what is happening to the
world and to yourself and to technology
and sexuality and medicine and spirit
and mathematics and art
and this drama of being
is now being waged on so many levels
at such an intensity that uh
the
metaphor
of saying history is like a science a
psychedelic experience is actually
giving way to
the demonstrable fact of the matter
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you